welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and now that Hugh Jackman has
confirmed to return as Wolverine in the
MCU in Deadpool 3 suddenly all those
X-Men movies many of you thought you
could skip every other one of are
actually important Wolverine's death at
the end of the 2017 film Logan has now
come under question and the exact
timeline logic of Deadpool 2 in X-Men
Days of Future Past now Bears some major
weight on the logic of how Deadpool and
Wolverine could cross over into the MCU
for the past several years I've been
keeping a warm spot in my brain for all
the seemingly useless knowledge of X-Men
movie timeline logic and now it's
finally paying off we need to know
exactly what versions of Deadpool and
Wolverine are joining the MCU what
they've been through and what era of
Jack do you Jackman was because you know
if he's a variant from the 2000 X-Men or
a variant from the 2013 The Wolverine
that's a difference of like a few
thousand calories per day for him so the
first X-Men movie came out in the year
2000 but was stated to take place in a
not too distant future this was Hugh
Jackman's first appearance as Logan AKA
Wolverine and as a relative unknown he
didn't expect to get the part but he
said that then associate producer Kevin
feige took him out to dinner and after
Jackman was cast and director Brian
Singer banned comic books on set Hugh
Jackman would sneak over to Kevin
feige's Office to read comic books and
get a better understanding of the
character and ever since then the two
have always had a great relationship and
have been looking for ways to work
together again and now they finally can
X2 X-Men United takes place in 2003
X-Men the Last Stand in 2006 and then in
2009 Fox spun off the franchise into
X-Men Origins Wolverine this tracks
Logan's past as a child named James
Howlett in the 1840s and then an ageless
forever Soldier through the U.S Civil
War World War One World War II and then
in Vietnam the main events of the film
take place in the late 70s and early 80s
but the climax in 1981 as Logan faces
off against Ryan Reynolds Wade Wilson as
a version of Deadpool with his mouth
fused shut in 2011 Fox did a bit of a
reboot of the X-Men movies with X-Men
first Class starting a whole new lineup
of these mutant characters when they
were younger in the 1906 but since Logan
does not age she's still cameo in a bar
when the younger Professor X and Magneto
try to recruit him go [ __ ] yourself in
2013 a sequel to the 2009 X-Men Origins
movie came out called The Wolverine this
was the first one directed by James
mangle it opens with Logan and Nagasaki
when the bomb was dropped in 1945 but
then the rest of it takes place in the
present day so now we have two eras of
X-Men lineups an older one and a younger
one and in 2014 X-Men Days of Future
Past came out featuring both cast and
this movie is great it opens in the
post-apocalyptic future of 2023 and the
X-Men project Logan's mind back in time
to his younger body in 1973 to prevent
that dark future and as they
successfully changed the timeline the
events updates the Future Past erased
the X-Men timeline of everything that
happened after the year 1973 basically
it raised to the events of X-Men Origins
and Wolverine and erasing the things
that people didn't really like about X2
and X-Men the Last Stand leaving Logan
in a revised year of 2023 at the
expansion with Charles and cyclops Jean
Gray and the rest of the X-Men all of
them still alive this film is what makes
Logan such a critical Nexus character
now to respawn in Deadpool 3 and
potentially Avengers Secret Wars as a
regenerative mutant unstuck in time with
memories of alternate realities his mind
is flexible enough to maintain sobriety
across the Multiverse and balanced
memories of multiple lives so after Days
of Future Past the X-Men franchise
continued thereafter because Fox had to
keep pumping out X-Men films every two
years in order to maintain the rights to
the characters so in 2016 we got X-Men
apocalypse that is set in the year 1983
with the whole first Class cast of the
s-men and in that movie Gene and Scott
visit The Alkali Lake lab and run into
Logan shortly after his adamantium
surgery he's not in very good shape boy
is in good shape but you know not in
good shape and a follow-up to that movie
was 2019's dark Phoenix set in 1992.
there's no Wolverine in that one and
there's not much to take away from it
same for the New Mutants both these
movies are worth checking out but not
really many implications for future
events fall is officially here and that
means it's time to start taking the
three main Falls of fall seriously I
mean of course the falling leaves the
falling temperatures and falling asleep
you've probably already got a rake and a
cozy sweater and I bet you think you've
got a mattress that's perfect for
falling asleep on but unless you've got
a helix Sleep mattress you are not
taking falling asleep seriously enough
Helix sleep makes premium mattresses and
betting customized to fit your needs and
shipped right to your door and look I'm
not a sleep apologist or anything but I
don't need to be Helix is a sleep quiz
that matches your unique body type and
your sleep preferences to the perfect
mattress for you you can even take it
with a partner and find the mattress
that's a perfect compromise between your
preferences I took the quiz I wanted a
medium firm mattress with lumbar support
that sleeps cool and I got matched with
the dusk Luxe Helix mattress I've had it
for a few months and I absolutely love
it I sleep better and I wake up less
often than I used to feeling links
delivers your mattress right to your
door for free it comes rolled up in a
shockingly tiny box and super easy to
set up yourself Helix has a 100 night
sleep trial so you'll get more than
three months to make sure that you love
your mattress if you don't they'll pick
it up for you and you'll get a full
refund and these mattresses also have a
10 year warranty that is an entire
decade Helix even has financing options
in flexible payment plans so a great
night's sleep is never far away I love
my Helix and I think you would too so if
you're looking for a new bed check out
Helix you can click the link below or go
to helixsleep.com rockstars and get up
to 200 off your Helix mattress but in
2017 was James maegel's follow-up to the
Wolverine Logan which is set in the year
2029. mangle chose that year it's about
five or six years after the ending of
Days of Future Past and in this future
all of the X-Men had been killed off by
one of Charles Xavier's psionic seizures
leaving Logan is the only one left to
take care of him it is in this movie
where Logan dies killed by his clone x24
now Deadpool came out in 2016 in
Deadpool 2 in 2018 and both of these
seem to occupy a parody side reality
that's adjacent to the X-Men like a
Deadpool 2 the X-Men apocalypse cast
cameos and they're the age that they are
in the 1980s despite its being the
present day so when it comes to Deadpool
3 Ryan Reynolds and Hugh Jackman kind of
started to explain how is Wolverine
alive yeah after Logan Logan uh takes
place in 2029 a totally separate thing
Logan died in Logan not touching that
and as all this blew up on social media
Logan's director James mengel tweeted a
gif of Logan's death by x24 and followed
up saying Logan will always be there
Multiverse or prequel Time Warp or
Wormhole Canon or non-canon or even
without a rationale I cannot wait to see
what Madness my dear friends cook up and
to that point Deadpool 2 does end with a
bunch of timeline Shenanigans Deadpool
uses a time travel wristwatch that he
got from cable to go back to visit
Wolverine in the year 1981 to kill his
alternate self and tell that era of
wolverine look eventually you're gonna
hang up the claws and it's gonna make a
lot of people very sad but one day your
old palway is going ask you to get back
in the saddle again and when he does say
yes and so when Ryan Reynolds mentions
2029 it tells us that Reynolds has done
his homework on Logan highly respects
that film and intends on Logan's death
in that movie Staying an absolute
endpoint for the character but since
Hugh Jackman Wolverine is the one
constant among all the fox X-Men movies
Deadpool really can't find him from any
point in this history from the year 1981
and thereafter and then explore an
alternate Branch timeline for the
character in The Multiverse X-Men Days
of Future Past ending in the year 2023
might be a bit of divine coincidence for
Kevin feige or maybe part of his genius
plan because 2023 has been kind of the
magic gear that he's been using in the
MCU 2023 is when the blip ends in
Avengers end game and has kind of been a
bit of a calendar year zero for phase
four and Beyond Spider-Man no way home
and Hawkeye are set in December 2024 Ms
Marvel and She-Hulk have been set in
2025. we still haven't gotten to the
year 2029. we know Kevin feige considers
days of Future Past important because in
Multiverse of Madness Charles Xavier
calls back his own mind from that film
meanwhile feige also obviously considers
the first X-Men important because that
recent Easter egg and She-Hulk shows the
headline man fights with metal claws and
bar brawl which is a not too Wolverine
specific introduction in that 2000 film
and we also know that feige's plan for
the beginning was to casually imply
these mutants might already exist in the
MCU based on the original version of the
Iron Man post-credits scene in 2008. as
if gamma accidents radioactive bug bites
an assorted mutants weren't enough
but you could look at the events of 2023
in the MCU continuity and conclude that
the infinity stone Cosmic radiation
blasts might have altered reality in a
specific way to blip a number of X-Men
into the MCU and our Hugh Jackman
Wolverine is that man with the metal
Clause referenced by the headline
personally I would prefer the MCU
Wolverine could have been part of the
shared World War II History part of that
Legacy of super soldiers after Steve
Rogers but after the success of
reprising Toby Maguire and Andrew
Garfield in no way home in this
announcement Avengers secret war is
clearly One path forward for these past
franchise cameos at least ones that they
might want to bring back once or twice
and then move on thereafter is the
Multiverse so feige will likely recast a
variant 616 Universe Wolverine in the
MCU but the Hugh Jackman Wolverine and
Deadpool 3 will be a universe Hopper who
likely picks up with Logan after the
events of X-Men Days of Future Past and
before his death in Logan extracting him
as a variant from that 2023 Nexus point
the way Loki was extracted from the 2012
Time Heist Nexus point to avert his
death and pursue a new Destiny in the
Multiverse luckily for Hugh he kept his
shirt on at the End of Days of Future
Past so 2023 Logan doesn't have to box
kangaroos to get into shape so what are
the key X-Men movies to watch to
understand Wolverine's arrival in the
MCU all of them let's start with the
first X-Men in 2000 and X-Men Days of
Future Past the two Deadpools and Logan
that's it just those five I mean again
all of them especially X2 is really fun
X-Men first Class also really fun but
those five are the required viewing or
required re-watching better get started
you only have uh two years follow me on
Tick Tock Instagram and Twitter at eavos
follow new rockstars subscribe ninja
rockstars for more analysis of
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]
thank you